let's now dog you see yep what's so fool
to our people on YouTube live what's up
everybody out there hello who are
desperately waiting to find out who's
gonna win the local contest all bad we
should have had a not just announce the
winners we should have a local funniest
content we said hell no - no I'd like to
see those ones dogs some of them were
just like whoa wrong microphones with
hair yeah what about just look like I
had Yosemite Sam feed bro bring the feed
into it it was a little shadow war one
and then man there was some people who
just didn't draw anything but just went
through it even us here all mad I will
shut your head of time over the funny
one it's crammed on I would have
probably wanted that I woke up this
morning to some hilarious [ __ ] bro
detail Jerry for voodoo brought
beatboxing well like eat boxing bro come
on man
just trying to sell some product over
here man dusty as Paris we'd get that
Kate Kate tail microphone yeah I guess
eh yeah cut weed they like snip weed at
a dispensary now that's their job he
doesn't car cab anymore coming up in the
billion dollar business that's what they
say you know so now it's doing by no
drink so Noah would snip beyond I think
I would get bored at that job like bored
to tears but a guy like cocky man got a
cocky cocky without the exposure right
his last name is so losito okay guy
what's the other one look lemon a guy
[Laughter]
as his brother all right it's funny bad
ways with you for you when you beat
brothers and you cools both brothers but
what brother always talks bad about the
other brother
I don't know why do we do that but I
don't know they're picking sides for the
tomorrow and he tell you that nice to be
a cracker now brother Rock Monster
I get was a rock monster bro do you know
why he was doing that he was deflecting
focus we're bang on his ass he like
what's a black my brother and my brother
was are like a crack fiend bro like he
knew every scam to get crack even even
like sleeping outs like sleeping outside
a gas station boy waking up bro
or laying in the floor to somebody or
give money
everyone's hate told me that nah man
once I was taking out a terrible time
some lady gave me $100 lucky then she
wanted me but you wanted me to do to her
house we take a bath
and I said no Disney buddy you're
sitting there waiting for money or banjo
Oh angel like James Caan my brother
angel a lot of people talking about dead
bro have a look darling no bro we like
down it out bro like a hobo status bro
black dick in the living in the gas
station and somebody that you ain't Jew
that you dog yeah it's me man oh man
whatever to you brother Felipe oh man
he's dead man
I just haven't done it I I haven't let
it go bad just been poor I don't know
man like my boy man it's a lie dog and
then the guy was reading anything I
think I forgive the boy like 60 bucks
good lie though
see bro you're a crack here like my like
I used to be and he used to be you don't
need an acting class bro because if you
relied for money and begged and got it
he was born on the stage did those
stories ever get back to your mom or
your dad and then go back to me
did anybody ever run into and say what I
brought that you were dead brother rehab
but eyes huh crazy dog
all right man upcoming shows Lincoln
California Thunder Valley Casino in
Sacramento area sold out they're gonna
release 40 ticket but there were there
gonna be 40 ticket not sitting together
so but I don't even think I think
they're giving those away to some VIP
VIP is rollers I think it's very
important people Pablo's people Pablo's
Salt Lake City have wiseguys the brand
new Jordan landing location may 10
through 12 I will be the with Rodrigo
Torres Johnny Sanchez
maybe Toby Hicks taco shape he has a
little rocky raccoon eyes like good
Johnny Sanchez hey man we're brothers
bro binoculars I'm going uncovered to
NatGeo Colorado Ashley is Ignacio
Colorado at Sky you'd casino may 13 all
right improv in Irvine California May 12
27 Murr might be there
okay Miami may 31st at Magic City casino
I'm headlining their ultimate Miami
comedian competition closing it out with
one hour long set you know what's funny
about that show it's a comedy cartoon
right I guess the winner goes up before
me or there's a lot of comedians
yeah right before you they get to do
another set right before you there's
already comedians posted oh they're
opening up for me I'm legally working
with him you were the best five and I
landed at seven you did open up for me
disclosure right there
okay look plug the little show for the
weekend all right back well dock at
sages weekend dad
nice lappers comedy died a p.m. I'll be
there with Tobey Hicks
oh I'm through with you that's this
Saturday the 20th a p.m. say - shut up -
Tobey Hicks podcast - yo check out the
dope dealers podcast on the company pop
up his daughter booked our AT&T
commercial a shout out to mrs. little
Toby Hicks what's right there's two of
them right wrong with the hair the books
so yeah congratulations to Zion another
both oh yeah I mean we come from an
artistic family Nebraska what's up fool
check out all the show that Felipe's
world.com slash tour because i'm adding
new dates all the time
man what's up we were Albuquerque bro
bouquet bouquet what's up oh man I tore
up a fright as soon as I got there man
they give us 45 dollars of food to spend
and my dog has this my dumb ass
uses it our room service and I still
have enough [ __ ] buddy
$45 okay I had only I ordered three
fried bread tacos
they're big like a mini size pizza fry
bread is the best fry breath delicious
it is bomb its flour and water that's it
and let me we'll fried and they put a
bunch of beans on it
lettuce tomato welcome only [ __ ] that
up you makes it go green sock chili that
she's good
so out of those three onion rings fries
two cokes - it came out - $52 $52 on
eBay about to take one of your pouches I
gave you one oh you gave it to me $50
did I give it to the guy and I threw out
the tipper but I don't think we got no
tip on about your house no yeah what
what happened was you pay $50 for some
brave handsome dog y'all paid $50 for
three bread he still don't even try it
the best part of them the breads good
dude but that chili that's the best time
actually like hot like nice and hot
though not yet another one I put some on
the Tina case I made little chilaquiles
there were good brownie like given with
a green hatch without that comedian
while that comedian he's a new comic
what do you say about George Lopez who
fool that fool I gave you that that
badass starting ah yeah yeah he's
starting comedy and he went out there
and homeboy hooked him up give him like
500 bucks I heard about to shut up and
leave so much the Dodger game the next
day everybody wanted I left this bat poo
like a fat but he carefully play oh man
like parting his heart I really want the
Hat because I know what they be I know
what it be easy what he go I know what
that happy they Samina beast pile of
books press I just did that hat bro you
totally dollars for a take about 20-30
Albuquerque bro yeah you should I can't
give you a gift oh really what the Hat
but beg you bro but you do baby her
photos he after he gave him one he want
anymore
why their food I gave her their hat well
you gotta go [ __ ] through the shoulder
yeah okay I broke you gotta go to comedy
shows
don't y'all are the comedian's don't
annoy especially if you're a [ __ ]
comedian or trying to be one yeah that's
like a lot I know it's cool you at a
networking [ __ ] but come on and also man
don't yell out [ __ ] that people don't
understand what you're talking about
like this for yelling oMG Pancho you and
two people know what the [ __ ] you're
saying it I think it's please he was
nervous he couldn't let out his whole
thing dogs he's all sentence we wanna
say I love the episode of MC by Joe
throw your legs apart you fool we wanted
something now dude empty poncho
hey that fool went to Logan Park in San
Diego and could somebody head up the
airlock ha
why are you logging right there but you
look better location Logan
some artists took a bunch of photos kind
of like it's Devin Oreos photos but they
were they were like in color okay but
they're just of people of San Diego you
know they make a long wall photos and
they may want to ever see Pancho hell
yeah dude oh he's on one of the mural
things you have anyone over there he
didn't see him though
yeah but the funniest day was the shout
out the empty partial gave to the art if
I put him up there
what was it you could you do yourself
well I would just want to thank
everybody for uh you know rendering my
image and the nameless artist somebody
de couple words that's my man right
there no but she said that I was deep oh
man see my photo it up much lobby you
know an artist your family yo ha yeah
not to be a dick I just think it's fun I
like how it is all like enclosure the
Sun doesn't hit all that [ __ ] always
badass with you never forget bad
understand Diego and Lisa we're at the
Sheraton at the resort right and I just
just like I want to see who else has
been here
but there was one dude from will bring
photos Compton that one brother right he
was say man I wanna feel smoke in her
blood and I standing outside of where I
was sitting yet he said man San Diego do
we did there's something about her [ __ ]
early to come out here man and get away
for the monotony of the hood that we're
doing it matter
yeah what was that the Mission Bay
Resort I think yeah
I went down there I loved that place we
were outside were just chilling there
brother waters just right there and it
there was a bunch of people from Silicon
Valley playing frisbee outside bro
what's up with Marty Moorhead no bronies
don't play they did this frisbee golf
got that Olympian blood in them are you
into that
give me a break dog really what's next
lawn bowling charts no way dude out on
darts maybe bowling inside that way you
should kill people yeah we knew somebody
that got there kid a lot of people [ __ ]
loaded hard oh my god you're like
straight-up drunk like drugged and then
you look we're all side Sheila we were
outside of patio we had that badass
patio these people level all in ha ha
it's like that's what to leave gets a
DUI that place oh yeah dude not
everybody was staying there dog yeah
both fool well I was full for a day
because I actually need to make a small
fry bread I made it one time for us what
a long time ago like eight years ago
what Kevin Weber it was good cuz my
friend was my friend was sue and her her
mom made us cry but she was sooo Indian
they were her mom was a hundred percent
like she grew up on the reservation say
that this time they were better than the
last year I think I'm sorry I don't know
why though
but yeah she would make fry bread and I
just loved it I thought it was the best
thing and I was I was trying to get my
mom to learn how to make it because it
was so cheap and I you know we don't
have any money for food but you know -
Freddie Freddie thanks for being a guest
yeah man short mug Elliot was so food
doc DXF 420 yeah man rest in peace Mitzi
shore bro yeah man she supposed to be
twice actually
eight times she spoke to me when I was
trying to be a regular for eight weeks
she told me come back next week
come back next week well she's tapped me
on the shoulder come back next week and
when I find she finally passed me she
said Karl in four spots but my dumb ass
and then I'm calling a couple of times
they're like okay you get frustrated we
don't get a spot so you go somewhere
else you know so I'm sure oh and then
she spoke to me also at the Latino
laughs after what acaba at the Latino
laugh afterwards San Antonio where she
went to show time she was hanging out
with Brian Holtzman she was like Brian
Howe Smith gasps at the San Antonio
comedy was Brian Holtzman's gasps yes
pull that one yeah she was mad to wear
the collar Mencia went up the stage and
um she's she's she's the one instead
like what's going on but uh and also her
Freddy Soto passed away she uh she
called over it to me and I spoke to her
into the car and then she tapped my
shoulder she said how you doing I'm
doing good thank you for asking
so yeah what's so fool she knew who I
was England shut up - Ingrid hello we're
so Floyd 79 England in the house keeping
it 100 over there shiny like lord Benton
Alex Castellanos the guest today he's
right here
[Laughter]
to be bright white back come on down man
come on ladies and gentlemen
he doesn't anybody's like 30 years over
on there she's gonna hook you up right
shut up - I'll tell you funny about I
will get it oh sorry my raising the ball
no no no that's yours yeah what not it
doesn't look like it's seated in there
very yeah it's kind of loose
hello jack so who's you know what I
don't even need a man of many phobias
over here as well
oh it's okay it's all right I'll use
that actually yeah give it give me those
ones oh oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah did weak success there's
gonna work oh hell yeah
are you in okay now oh yeah what up dog
right on man England but then I think
you're gonna talk about the wine know
about that thing or that I mean the
neighborhood music thing
oh I went to the food giver her daughter
oh we went to I I'm a donor bro for the
music house neighborhood music school
neighborhood you think school in Boyle
Heights
right there on Boyle Avenue across the
street from the Japanese home this is a
big is that the only Victorian home ever
saw in my neighborhood I grew up in a
housing project down the street Pico
Gardens Pico Ali so Ali so village shout
out and now I'll say oh no I want to go
in their house one day but I've never
bothered to go I mean I could have
easily just will endure it not teach me
how to play piano and it would help me
it's been around for that long
14 oh wow so please say that we donate
money cuz they give kids free classes
they give kids read classes some kids
actually pay but the one who can't or
donation scholarship so we got everybody
brought to know a tea party how was it
what we both got say grow now put your
tea party and he had a free wine three
types of wine they had lemon
bro a bunch of the macaroon cookies yeah
and I'm vegan bro but you wanna taste it
so - a little nip oliver still give me
gas to make up a whole way [ __ ] yeah no
bad milk give me gas nothing now bees
won't even give me gas but about milk
like if there's a scent of milk and
anything I taste a dairy real Jerry
right in any food my stomach knows bro
yeah I heard thunder Brule yeah the book
was the big yeah here's a quick reaction
to milk these cabbage broccoli and I
know where something has meat bro cuz it
tastes so good I mean I could tell what
it has meat cuz I demand I want to
Dodger Stadium and we were sitting in
the bottom with a free food and the good
food chicken and waffles
I had now I asked think I could have two
budgetary
dogs so I bit into it as a Mallee
[ __ ] that's holy sour meat no he
said I don't think they're vegan I don't
think they are I looked at him and I
just saw the seam and I thought yeah
it's the fake all right so I swallow
there bro I took the first bite no I
took the first bite it was disgusting I
said this is it's not vegan and he said
that's what I thought I told him that
after but I'm sure you there now and
then I want to order something else and
I could tell I have milk in it so I had
something edible food and by about 3:00
in the morning bro
Oh bro I use the river like it was bad
bro
I would like like it felt like right
away do like my stomach was hurting dude
and then ever they like it was ugly bro
[Laughter]
I thought I would put a window toilet
and felt like someone threw a grenade in
there and let her say everybody live by
city honey and then we we were drinking
a bunch of stuff right and then least a
drink of why there in my defense I
hadn't had anything to eat but Lisa I
took a toast for blue egg sandwich which
is broke yeah I took a little bit of egg
sandwich but I took the cucumber
sandwich was fine and then but the kids
were serving us and all that stuff so I
felt bad saying this I took some bites
but it was the wine that got me man cuz
I had three glasses of wine which isn't
bad but I think they're only there for
an hour so it was bad then everybody was
there was like everybody there was like
a big big donors there were charges of
stuff I bet there was the main guy there
was some dude from USC he looked a DJ
you would see for Jack USC radio DJ I've
heard him before why do we throw on the
way out if we're waiting but I don't
want y'all she's here with me but I feel
like a peak Miami Vice Jack your dog
don't wanna hear stories well you said
it was a DJ from USC Jess yeah I mean
the the jazz radio station yeah listen
that's Cal State Long Beach
oh I don't Chapman I think you just said
USC radio is all the way out there who
took the time I joke all about the
choker part how many be in our beds to
the titty to reliable you don't know
because you weren't there
hello he told me what it was a Larry
thong nobody talked after he told you
that joke I was glad that he sat next to
him bro he said out how many lives how
many family does it take to change a
lightbulb and then I said I don't know
he said that's offensive tea party bro
after the tea party will do ha boo oh
hell yeah I don't remember leaving -
really he's a blogger bro but why not
you that bad I drank a glass of wine
this past weekend I don't drink it that
much it got me by yeah man told me over
the ethic because you know drinking car
I'm drinking wine out of a Tupperware
cover
I think but listen I threw up outside my
car I threw up like I was like trying
that's because he was driving home the
window outside the door and it was just
like all over the car I had to take it
to the I felt like that's gross no what
did it look like we're driving brother
I'm first of all she drove to the
Chinese bomb I remember that I wasn't
hit me as I sat down so a man I'm
cheated laid by you know where to
maneuver so uh only to Ireland people
people are chasing me bro anyway so
start feeling sick man she roll up the
window man and I look back and then all
that window bros are thrown in the car
my hair but I don't get grossed out I
might throw up or I would throw up I
don't get grossed out by anything like
that but I can throw it up oh if I smell
it I see it it's over
they just say the the the one was just
cheap I bet she is because it's free of
course and lush but she's
creaking alarm and Sheila said next to
Lisa I attract them she goes uh
Catskills you know I pay for his wife is
my donation and I told him it's for the
neighborhood school give me a discount
[Laughter]
and she was on her like fourth or fifth
class I don't know how long she had been
there she was talking about was so full
Bray Wyatt back right here uh-huh
I bet Hamed or a relative what's a long
time about the airport river yeah and
return guests by the way at where first
first time I thank know I mean I've been
I've seen you pocket probably but you
know what we went to Phoenix we saw him
and he was doing his pop-up podcast
right you did yeah yeah I mean we were
in Phoenix at the same time okay I mean
I see you on the shows but he never been
on the podcast yeah good Ontario there
was another one we did - I think Brea
right oh maybe maybe so yeah yeah anyway
I mean you know I'm we're around oh so
maybe that's why you know there's a
familiarity you know look at this guy
right here man what up these people are
comics yes you [ __ ] we're not
being funny right doesn't understand
little combination I'm not a comic I'm a
CPA I do I do have late base tax it's
gonna be funny huh car cane card cake do
your own show bro go jerk off somewhere
okay james hylton blonde even wrote them
emoji means to start recognizing emojis
bro you must just mean muscles means
like only strong I guess we're just like
check out this check out this Brian bro
have to only chance to prefer this to be
funny look you know he's back would you
like a heckler at the end of the show
bro you see the way I helped you exactly
yeah heckle Brent oh yeah sure what do
yellow just like you know stupid stuff
you know stuff like poncho what was that
thing they said punch over yeah yeah em
say bunch of video they yeah I don't
know they just yell out whatever you
know I don't know like try remember now
actually just like I mean I usually kind
of just ignore it though for the most
part unless it's like really loud you
know then I have to address it I guess
if they're just like being too much you
know but it's been a while since I've
gotten like hardcore heckles you know I
mean one time this guy was like I did
something I mentioned something I
mentioned the word the word gay and this
guy in the audience said he started
chanting something I can't remember was
now but he started chanting we want
funny we want funny something like that
just because I mentioned the word gay
and you got a little religion you got he
got offended at that right and so he
just started doing that and then I was
like I don't I think I brought him on
stage and I kind of I don't know I
forgot I think I just started chanting
along with him or something comes be hey
cool it was bad bro
and he started yelling got their part oh
that that part of Scarface
[Music]
okay when you speak echoed the room was
chaos like it was loud already and he
received Scarface when they're at the
freedom camp and they tow Scarface I'm
Tony Montana hey there's a guy there
that Fidel Castro released out of prison
he's one of it he's one of his what
Islam torturers in all he's here freedom
camp if you kill him
we'll give you a passport he goes for a
passport I'll deliver him right so when
they were out during all that chaos that
guy running with his suitcase
and then stuff and then what's the name
of that actor brozen name Manolo Stephen
Bauer Stephen burrows out there named
God and then stabs or broke and kills
their food actually actually opportunity
um but that no one got that heckle but I
[ __ ] a reference to hydro because this
can be heckled hard the rule were
yelling at him it was chaos and it's
somebody for the backwards banner God
perfectly awesome man well Nick [ __ ] you
on a yacht down through the communion of
those big-ass years and you try to get
the crowd back and somebody you know
check out the rally monkey have you ever
had stuff thrown at you
[ __ ] yeah bro that's I remember that
more than the the heckles you know yeah
I've had like a lime thrown at me from
someone's drink it through a lime it's
like classic I mean that's a classic
like getting fruit thrown at you it
should you know I got a old yeah and
then someone's like spit Tommy was a
baby stroller at me bro top him in San
Francisco and I got like yes they were
yelling that [ __ ] out Freddy leave let's
start leave I'll stop that [ __ ] worst
party
yeah then we gotta let out leave
Leo my god it was so [ __ ] funny when
you got off the stage I sit down yeah I
would he go though however you get up
the stage and I stayed take a look at
the bad guy anyway so back to you
oh I you know anyway I mean I got in
your whatever wet napkins thrown at me
and stuff like that you know whatever I
mean it's easy to talk he hit me I mean
he almost hit me - the bottle on that
rail Wow what it would put him off cuz
that's right when the new uh the gay law
came in like gay marriage Oh what's up
you guys on the first date and that
philosophy
yeah yeah no III I did that I did
something to that but the same thing
it's the loogie came at me though but
and I thought it hit me but it actually
went right over my shoulder fortunately
i'ma come out after the show did you
kick him nah would you get over a fever
sweater fried thrown at you in Chicago
that oh you got a lemon but she wasn't
heckling really she was just drunk and
then I was gonna escalate but you know
I'm gonna kick they're gonna kicked
around but like 30 minutes he ain't
after another 30 minutes I don't wanna
take the attention from her getting
kicked out so just ignored it so then I
made it funny and she was all happy and
they came back every year then she was
excited when I get exciting though a
lemon of greedy
I guess that's holy she's from Puebla
that's how they stay high all their
guests
but that I've had I'm adding some more
guy threw a bottle at me oh it was a
bottle hit you wrote hell no him is bro
yeah yeah he flicked it bro it was some
more than I flicked it with a finger bro
okay oh no a whole bottle the whole
bottle he flicked the whole bottle with
his finger yeah that's a morning that
wasn't one of those airplane sighs but
it didn't hit me bro but he waited
outside for me too he was ba but even a
big like up like Booya tribe April he
was big like Phillipe as far as a family
being he was like my height but just
strong but drug bro but still like you
know he he was doing even new shoes yeah
bro he's doing a little dance Allah
whatever and then he will [ __ ] out he
stood outside with a knife bro but it
was like one other night but he was too
drunk to take out the blade so he took
out the word the file size it was a
swiss knife yeah he didn't take out the
blade part he was too loaded so he took
at the fireside and he started I beg you
to join Medina's car bro oh that's when
you guys disturb the karaoke yeah he
took his out bro it was a Jurassic Park
to ride bro we go t-rex to drop it in a
car so yeah jumped in the car and that's
when he did that yeah we took we took
our bro and then I left
truly a set left over I guess
[Music]
what's up food what did you start
stand-up comedy yeah I started in San
Francisco but I grew up here though in
Los Angeles though because I moved there
for college and then I stayed after
college stayed in San Francisco and uh
you know just did stand up there so I
was based there from where did you grow
up Italian in Hollywood Hollywood next
to with all like the Russians and
Armenians well Armenians yeah like I
went to high school in the valley even
though I grew up in on the Hollywood in
the Hollywood side and there was a lot
of Armenians in my high school but you
know I used to take karate lessons at
sunset and Gardner you know with all the
Russian kids it's like a Russian karate
it's funny how when you to like is weird
like I like you kidding really
when you the Russian man cuz I had to go
to the YMCA man [ __ ] are hairy
well it was definitely very there was a
lot of sweat I like you gonna get a chop
to an egg misses you you stupid of Sweat
right exactly you miss you definitely
get spray you get sprayed but he spoke
karate with 10-qs they used to cheer
each other on
like they used to like what if you were
like fighting or whatever you'd hear
people cheering each other on and
there's they say things like come on
Vlad faster faster big [ __ ] big [ __ ]
bust a move bust a move I don't know why
they would say that but they would say
big [ __ ] and bust a move to cheer each
other on
and they'd say mama said knock you out
also come on be [ __ ] big [ __ ] mama
said knock you out
never you get your Russian joke from
yeah you know it is to some degree yeah
it was always there was a lot of just
Russian accent action at that karate it
was right there there's a big Russian
neighborhood right there yeah everyone
Willie Barcena and his kid was going to
karate class in the fridge the first day
that fella went there we saw that
structure and say wow man you know he
looks young for we teach you karate had
a mustache nothing laughs let's just do
them bro the little kid had a must at
the ready boy oh no they definitely
developed quicker than other kids I
remember it was really smoke marbles but
there was a kid in my elementary school
who he was the first kid I get pubic
hair he had pubic hair for anybody and
like we had a party one time and
everybody was I remember we like all
watched a video and I heard that we were
gonna go swimming and people were
changing their trucks and stuff and I
heard Frank get over here quick and I
ran in I ran into the bathroom and where
this one of the brushing guy was
changing this is an elementary school
kid he had a full bush and I remember
this other friend of mine was like it's
a jungle in there
oh he was like ten that's what you
thought your old Olympian in there huh
we're whole lab I don't develop here to
like 11th grade bro I probably didn't
get I definitely got ball here first you
know I don't know if that was the same
for you guys but the buck the ball here
came in first and that was like nah
probably like 12 or 3 people are pretty
out here first
I had one pubic hair that came out like
in the ninth grade this one they came
out they got released brother man two
mice a comb in and [ __ ] I I remember
getting my first give it a name great
pubic hair do you have any or white
white pube occur it was just one that
came out like I don't came out early -
you go gray early yeah I started getting
gray one at 16 but I got the first gray
pubic hair when I was like I don't know
22 or 21 or something like that but it
was it was the one gray pubic hair for a
long time you know the special is the
special chosen one you know by 12 great
relative no a little bit of hair you're
not that hairy in general I mean even
though you have a lot of hair on your
head you're not a hairy person we're
talking about there was this kid named
Chris and he was young but he didn't
have no hair younger than me like five
years younger than me and we were
talking about it and then he hit him he
had a brother that wasn't kind of like
huh
I think he's Reba pause your but
mentally [ __ ] they I guess what else
we were policy but that's we were policy
but this guy was like [ __ ] Asian again
but you were the school now say though
I'm here down syndrome right so he
brought that for siding on the way bro
and I fooled like he was a wooden egg
right and I put down his source
uncle ah y'all wanna see here this who
has here then he put his pass back up
and put it back in the house
go back and sit on your chair that will
have thousands that does it the right
down syndrome is what they used to call
[ __ ] is outside and get himself in
like it not like a yoga position Bo's
and lay down there's lots of different I
mean they were there's some that are
really you know high functioning and
they're just normal well personally it's
just varying degrees of being affected
by it so some people can like there and
without actors and with that varying
degrees of hair does not have all his
faculties you know and that's he's
abusing that guy that's that those who
live for a long time dude
but what's out is they outlive their
parents usually their parents are older
not always although they can be born to
young parents too but much more rare
rarely than give five dollars to the
haters these some weirdos in this group
today do you want to talk more about
Brent and his special or New Year's
break take a break for the logo contest
and then oh yeah that's right whatever
you want a logo contest so break whoo
look at him okay so we had about 50
entries fifty a lot of them missed mark
completely okay was saying with a lot of
microphones with hair you wanna think it
was 230 over the other way looked when
they were done by kids did you always
have long hair by the way
no yeah but Yuri shaved bald never know
what kind of comedy my hair was about
oh really yeah I saw a stand-up comedy
with my hair with a board I would just
shave it off I don't know why but I
would didn't have long hair because my
dad allow it to have it that's
interesting
you didn't have facial hair are there no
yeah a little bit yeah no no I still
doesn't really come
okay I have a balding spot right here
all right all right so we got it down to
five that we felt was fine there about
50 some tried to enter twice yes wait
how many will see it because the cameras
here so even though we don't get to see
it here Philippe it with John Goodman
right there all right so this is the
first you're the Big Bopper brother
focus go guys time for a row all right
this is the first one this is kind of
like a sports yeah it feels very sports
like okay this looks like a sports
podcaster Regina right there to a ride
too late either buzzer get a stack of
Toby all right so that's Jose Sanchez we
like that one I kind of liked it
striking I like like the face is good it
looks like a baseball pocketable team or
some [ __ ] yeah that was the first
reaction by the way okay so then the
second one is oops this one by mondo
Patek
Oh it's like more cute style this is my
cheap style and I had him add Rodrigo
because that was gone but actually I
think that looks more like Rodrigo than
the other one is by Diego Pimentel
that's the Big Bopper
this is Mexican style
now the images I had a problem with the
images we could have had them fixed but
I don't want to critique them all anyway
but we also kind of want to write that
one yeah the school it's not a weed
popular went to my like he got the
microphone you know but yeah a lot of
our guys have kids this is like kind of
like a Cypress Hill yeah
Day of the Dead I do like it but and
it's funny how Rodrigo looks very
different in every single illustration
or you know you don't like that [ __ ]
out that [ __ ] shows that movie with a
clown bro before became the cloud John
Wayne Gacy no God nothing that movie
brought with it yeah it um Batman no the
what was that Joker no jigsaw you know
it looks like you look buff in that you
look like you actually look like the
little a putty this one which is by Alex
Castaneda it looks like you should be on
that you gonna park right there huh that
one does look like Rodrigo I'm about to
say yeah my heroin pretty much took me
down they cropped your hair on that one
yeah I need a nap on that one it's like
beam angel about your Logan yeah what's
up fool itself in the Mexican blanket
back seat of a car or something my
problem with this though is well-worn we
can switch out fully based photo for a
better way but my problem is I can't
make it into shirts for one because it's
so busy and come to me no it's way too
much money is this happening to you guys
but the if I feel like the names are pot
like 3d almost I guess the colors are
something like that it's like popping
out feels like the names are coming off
bad teeth each other cover
I think it's a nice photo Rodrigo I
don't know but I like it but this is one
of our choices and then this one was the
last one almost a bit about a woman in
Africa a guy in Africa really from
Botswana its minimalist a nice color and
gradiation and we were like like a
backdrop for a show yeah my only issue
with this is it just doesn't really
capture the essence of the podcast but I
did like the submission it was simple it
was different I liked that one like if
we were to go go live and that logo
wasn't a microphone yeah yeah yeah but
okay so what we're gonna do what the
funny ones I don't have funny ones I
don't like that one so those were the
five okay oh man I do want to see the
funny ones beat us up I bet you I can
find something I like about it you know
I mean that's actually we should do is
to show the funny ones to see what we
can try to like them so we wanted we
wanted listener input so we let the
final voting up to you guys but it's
also our show's logo so we get to make
our own rules and this is what we're
gonna do we do have a fan favorite that
is a winner we have a show favorite that
is a winner and we have another favorite
that we're choosing but we're not sure
what to do with yet but we're gonna get
it to so we're gonna have three winners
or each gonna receive the $500 prize so
three winners yeah so one of the winners
will be the winner winner because well
the crowd favorite is not the favorite
of the show nobody was gonna be the logo
no our favorite the show favorite is
gonna be the logo the crowd favorite is
going to be for other things
this was the crowd favorite yes this is
Alex's Alex Castaneda got the crowd
favorite okay that was but only by a
little bit yeah because the next
one that'll be the poster we're thinking
of making this into a poster but I can't
make this into a logo it's a nice poster
it's a nice image I can't use it as a as
a branding tool I don't think it's
simple enough for that well it's a way
but it's a winner and so we might use it
for like live podcast that's like the
backdrop or a poster maybe for you know
if we do this 200th episode live podcast
that'll be the backdrop we would either
do that as a backed-up or we'll give
that out as free posters for the people
who come to the show something like that
we'll think of something but we're gonna
buy this one from Alex will need to
change okay and then the next one that
we're gonna choose is the other fan
favorite the number-two fan favorite was
this one and we had it actually it was
running without Rodrigo don't have me
for what I only had Felipe and it was
still the second fan favorite but
everybody was saying add Rodrigo of
course we were gonna have him at it so
he added it overnight in just like an
hour two hours maybe and it was a great
quality and I think it's great and this
is what we're gonna use as our logo so
this is the actual new Felipe's world
what it was tacos design and so he's
gonna be our actual stickers t-shirts I
like it it's simple but it's like that
and I can see it on iTunes I kind of
feel like it looks like the monopoly man
a little bit which I really like you
know it's cute and then we're going to
also purchase the third runner up
basically are the third in line fan wise
which is this one here and this is from
Jose Sanchez so this is going to be our
third Lowe's oh but this we don't know
what we're gonna do it or maybe just
make up custom baseball or a mug or
something you know coffee mug
a baseball mug yeah yeah so anyway
that's it so that's the that's the I
guess third place third place okay so
that's it so those are the three and but
I liked all them I like the skull in a
lot too it's just it's just not a little
let's go
don't change your mind now you like this
goal know what the Big Bopper oh you
don't like that [ __ ] that dude from
that superheroes movie which is the one
with Bruce Willis in it no the one that
read the cards will be although it does
look like an old Superman like a Max
Fleischer yeah that's super man to hold
George Reeves role I think this looks a
lot like Derek's life for the guy who
listens he and Ari I think it looks like
Derek's face here so we're drawing
oh you mean Christopher Reese yeah
captain incredible look like something I
remember what it is though it's it rises
so that Goonies like it's oh it does
look a little bit like that it's kind of
like um definitely look like an Italian
mafia guy or something like that
hey we were doing like add a little
Deadshot little contact this guy do
another one sure like all these people
have skills well mostly people have
skills so you know I might hit them up
for other kinds of Lobos like me because
they were like this they were like copy
and paste you know right I want to just
say F my FA Matsui Whitley cheery little
from Botswana Africa you know what
what's crazy that up a lot of people
from Africa were voting for that one at
night at midnight midnight to like six
hours
he was rallying he was rallying
everybody yeah the word what time is it
in Africa or in boats wanna at twelve
its are 1200 as well
it's 10:20 p.m. so nine hours ahead okay
so people wake people were in the
morning getting their day started and
you know going right to the that's what
they did for work is was so full podcast
was so geo Torres so you guys stand up
in um in San Francisco Bay Area you
probably know all the other people I
went to much to the cup to the tomorrow
tree all comedy festival yeah I went in
2005 yeah red Louie cats we can come out
come out though yeah yeah that's when
you went okay yeah yeah yeah I I've got
close that year myself actually but I
ended up doing Aspen that in February or
whatever for in 2006 those new Aspen
anymore huh no no I was I got in it was
cool it's a good feel still right what's
that well that aspic oh yeah yeah I was
HBO it was HBO and then rooftop comedy
took it over afterwards but it was good
to do it then because um later I would
go to Montreal and see how they treated
the new faces and it was like not as
good as if you did aspirin you know and
I was like oh it's a good thing I didn't
do it I almost was I thought I was
almost gonna go that year to actually
2005 wow you did a special with with
with new wave dynamics yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah but well for them to go
to Comedy Central or no what happened
was it was they had a deal with C so
alright which was never of NBC yeah and
it was like it was they were calling it
like a Netflix but for with cut for
comedy right and they had they did a
bunch of specials with them joy Gogol
Diaz Stanhope that's right and
oh they were those are all on see so
last year including mine
but um see so went out of business so
all the specials came down so a lot of
them went different places and then you
got the rights back or or comedy
dynamics yeah I guess I guess so I dunno
I think I own some of it I don't know
good portion yeah and then so then
anyway they just released it like a
couple weeks ago or
last week or whatever re-released it
because it wasn't available anywhere so
now it's available on iTunes and Amazon
and other streaming outlets you know
like Steam or whatever Google Play and
anyway so now it's back out and now I'm
just you know trying to tell people to
watch it weird that article it's on
Amazon any any streaming outlet places
that you can any stores you can just buy
it or rent it rent it the deal that you
got with Cecil did a good deal you think
it was better than your deal with the
Comedy Central I mean I would I wouldn't
it probably wasn't but it's the only
deal that I could get so you know for me
it was the best deal it was a better
deal than anything I would get with
Showtime
yeah let me take a compared to deal with
other people who don't know bro that's
his deal you deal with your deal and
you're evaluated yeah differently
depending on the platform I'm who's
booking those yeah I mean one would say
that I it was a bad deal but I mean for
me it was the best deal better than oh
yeah it was like you know I was I'm
grateful actually that I even got the
deal so um what were they hard for your
fans to go find us he sore yeah
especially people who live outside the
United States because well you couldn't
access you so anyway you know outside of
the United States even Canada you
couldn't get see so so so now
international people can get it so
that's cool you know now now people in
boats wanna can get it so people on
Amazon Prime who have Amazon video they
could look up your name and oh finally
there yeah but I think you have to
purchase it but I'm a little confused
cuz I did hear from somebody that it
will be available on Amazon Prime in a
few months so maybe people who already
have Amazon Prime maybe be able to just
see it without having to pay for it
separately but I don't know but as for
now you know you just have to go there
you have to rent it or purchase it but I
think it's funny the idea of renting the
special I mean it's like that's just
weird oh you movies but not special no
no it's just weird idea of renting a
special sounds that covers an ass it
that I rewrite jokes
the new age and you digitally but you
know but all I could say is that I think
if people check it out and they pay
attention there's there's more to it
than there's more just check it out
there's more in store this is your first
special yeah it's like this is like in
fact no not even up until now it's like
it's like the last seven years is not on
there so it's like it's like it was like
the probably the first ten years of like
my best bits from the first ten years of
stand-up which was a while ago but just
have all this stuff there's a old
material there where it wasn't on a
special so it's all on that so it's all
a lot of old stuff it's all old material
recorded at at Burbank at the colony
theater cool theater it's like a it's
it's a it's kind of intimate yet yet it
it's also kind of like stadium seating
and I like that and it's in Burbank it's
good it's good theater yeah we're the
Burbank but we're at what suite I don't
know it's in some kind of like big
building with other stores and stuff you
know I shot it actually on Ross the run
it's a colony theater at Ross sponsored
by Ross video that went viral right the
gangster oh yeah gangster party how is
that you wrote that yeah yeah I wrote
and directed it yeah yeah I'm in it for
a second - yeah I mean I think that
weird [ __ ]
we made a bunch of follow up ones -
actually we made a another one called
dad line where you can call different
dads you know if like you you need
guidance or you need discipline or
whatever you need advice or discipline
you can call the dad line call different
dads and then we did this one that was
like the hunk line where it's like it's
for ladies only but it's like they're
all super durable
you have one for people who don't want
to eat the rest of their food from a
show-up
food line what's though I got you on
those sandwiches actually if it's like
just a series of different dishes
they're different like food items like
you were like get a big pot stack off
what chicken and waffles and you can't
finish the rest of that meat
call me that's fine just one guy he'll
finish your meal for you
what happened Matt that fool is too
spicy I got lemons I got yogurt I got
you know and then we did another one
that was like a money line where people
can call in and ask for money they don't
get money but they can just call ask for
money and it cost $5 an hour or $5 a
minute to to call yeah we got $5 million
from Alex cotton here that oh he's gonna
call the line he's one of the winners he
paid us to win he's the winner and a 495
down to 495
yeah What's Up boo we also got coming up
uh nothing much you know your podcast
nothing okay well I got you know yeah I
got podcasts you know I got all kinds of
pocket like a podcast a new podcast
every week well I have I do three
podcasts there's one that's about video
game music that I don't know I don't
really recommend it because I mean it's
like it's it's really if you're into
video game music it's not even a comedy
podcast just it's about video game music
from the 80s and early 90s and if you
like yes not just like that and I don't
know anyway it's called legacy music
hour but then there's this one that I do
here that's called pointed questions or
just interviewed different people with
different professions like we had a
fireman and we had like a public
defender we had
like a mortician we had a model like a
runway model just different people and
just ask them interrogate and basically
of different questions just non-stop and
ask about weird stuff and then do the
southern one call the pound cast of my
friend DJ Doug down yeah we saw you
about they record your party oh yeah oh
yeah yeah right so every year - yeah I
mean I've gone in the past you know but
I don't really go that often yeah but
you get in everybody every year well
maybe yeah I don't know I think so yeah
he I got a text from him it's kind of
very informal right I get a text from
him and then like oh and then like then
I'm invited to the Eric Andre party
there's never like a complete test with
a date yeah but this time I knew ahead
of time that was gonna be there and
that's the case I'm gonna go to the
party and I went yeah that was all of
them oh yeah yeah what's the first one
he had in the apartment when he bought
that llama oh yeah yeah yeah I was at
that one too actually
that was crazy yeah yeah it was cool cuz
it was at his apartment with yeah just
this really low-key apartment in
Hollywood just plain old box apart yeah
under the carport yeah exactly that's
where were yeah but this last one was
pretty crazy right they do run naked huh
what about that guy he's in ladies there
was yeah they were like I saw three
people that were naked but that the one
guy with the like really big penis or
whatever the brother um yeah he was uh
he was in my that one of those videos I
was just talking about that dad line
video he was in the dad line video
although he's not the one on the one
that people can see unfortunately cuz
they made me cut him out because his
penis was too big now he's getting he
was he was David for some reason the
company that we made it for thought it
was creepy i don't know thought it was
creepy for some reason he wasn't naked
or anything but what do you say didn't
say anything we just called him
hilarious dad's and he just made this
big he had this big smile on his face
with big eyes and they thought that was
creepy for some I mean they were just
they were being very like particular
about a lot of stuff but that would we
show it at live shows and that get tons
of laughs but anyway that guy when we
met him
I just had no idea he was down to be
naked at a party for like 12 hours at a
party like he just seemed like a very
conservative kind of not conservative
but just an average kind of guy I mean
it didn't seem like he had a crazy
lifestyle you know and he had an
interesting look but man I just when I
saw a hundred party I was like what
that's the same guy and he's walking
around full-on naked naked dick out just
you know hanging I mean he was so free
and dancing and stuff I couldn't believe
it actually I was looking at him living
vicariously through I was just I just
couldn't believe it I was like I didn't
know he was like that I just didn't know
that side of him I was like I could have
used that you know see what everybody
gave me you play you play I think
whatever gig that you know he asked you
to do some stuff and you didn't they
didn't pay of course and oh yeah well
they like to announce him as he comes in
they were asking a lot of questions
about quintanilla nose and stuff like oh
yeah he was the creative consultant like
different things like that and then they
had like a run of the show and all that
stuff but they I don't think they were
paying anybody they just ask for favors
hey you wanna come to the party just you
know whatever we got through there was a
like four girls and begin putting
wrestling I saw a video did you get hit
with the everybody speaking of pudding
know what I was thinking
all right I did I just had this thought
today I was eating this um I got this
hummus that's chocolate
hummus it's actually made from you know
with hummus is made with garbanzo beans
[ __ ] yeah but it's chocolate and so it
may just taste like a chocolate spread
but it's good right and it made me think
you know how chocolate fondue is
basically just chocolate it'd be cool if
they made that made it with cheat with
the cheese so it was like the cheese was
chocolate
you know man so you getting a mix of the
fondue cheese and the chocolate that'd
be good I think what do you think like
you're dipping chocolate in the cheese
well you know no you're dipping
whatever bread or fruit or whatever in
to the this cheese chocolate really
cheese and chocolates good I'm thinking
this look have you ever done this yet
yeah like a cookie you know like a
chocolate chip cookie and you put some
cheese on it that's good it's Swiss
cheese with it you thought about do you
get high huh that's right yeah you never
drank never yeah wow your stories in
with actually that's my vices I don't go
to bed I stay up too late actually
they worry bro grazie Hollywood kid you
but then I would eat Doritos with a
third of your cheese well beat up it up
for cheese because I like nachos yeah I
would I will pull it a little piece of
cream cheese and then eat the chip you
got ok here it when I lived in the
section 8 housing in Colorado
this woman was 350 pounds and she would
scoop off a piece of butter with every
bite of soup and that's what you just
reminded me of right there actually no
it's good a sour cream with just chips
chips and sour cream just like don't
even worry about the salsa you know you
know you look the first time I ever
tasted any - you with chips dude mr.
Mitchell's class this falls off you guys
open up three things - Velveeta cream
cheese if I could pour one thing - sauce
over it and one thing I saw and we all
ate it with all that pizza money girls
with baby think that you guys know went
to school together so it was a homeboy
he used to have the Rideau bro and he
used to buy like either buy it or
shoplift that cream cheese the little
block you just would have tried it good
you take it out of the refrigerator and
you let it sit for 10 minutes breaking
or cheese that's it is bombed I like
that better than dipping in the in the
nacho cheese so what's the most our
butters to lady take a bite of that and
I'd buy that scoop of that just reminded
me she just sat there with a stick of
butter and took a little sliver of it
and then took it by the soup that's why
she's 350 pounds I mean it is it is the
answer I used to not like butter at all
on his ear but now I'm starting to
understand it a little more I mean not
to that degree but I understand be like
yeah maybe what do you want on your
bagel butter cream cheese both boy you
put you put our butter on one side bro
you team it on that fryer then you put
more butter and then you put a lot of
cream cheese on the other one bro so
that's a stock genius taste she's a
vegan butter bro are you just getting
get some you know some just some grunt
ground but salt on the cream cheese that
could be kind of fun or pepper I would I
like that fine yeah I'd be fun it you
know just how like the hard salt rule
like I like a creek I liked it
soft and crunchy at the same time you
know you get the crunches from the taste
buds of a serial killer over here and
also you know what's good Pendleton that
you should try it you get a chocolate
chip cookie and you add potato chips
good it's good it's also you get a chewy
you know the best chocolate chip cookies
in the in Los Angeles where Subway
sandwiches oh yeah I mean it's Double
Tree Hotel
I owe those are the no seriously like
you wouldn't you think it would be some
artisan style place or whatever Subway
sandwiches has the best chocolate chip
cookie it's like by the book is there
chocolate chips and that cookie never
melted both too hard it's there's a warm
little hard there good it's a perfect
consistency and the other don't worry
about the other cookies but the
chocolate of regular chocolate chip
cookies the subway are really good you
put some salt and vinegar potato chips
on it's good you know you know we find
those of satis add a slice of pizza
eleven o'clock and I brought everything
like a wafer broker I guess too hesitant
someone's gonna buy it yeah a little
hard-ass little topper you asked for it
broke [ __ ] [ __ ] up no hell no
99-cent stuff I know the one on Sunset
on the other side by cross the street
from Home Depot it was in LA I wanna
turn Apple boosters oh when you went out
how were they I think you will read
airport that's a picture I show to
Marcella today we know you know what's
the Midori that's what you said are you
some authority like if I do or not
you're you Filipino - yeah yeah new way
bro yeah yeah brain brain bakla Brett
Butler I was gonna ask you dude you said
you was Hollywood crazy when you were
like right before you went to college
and all that [ __ ] was like yeah yeah
definitely I mean they definitely spirit
after I left he definitely spruced it up
you know like with with you know the
Kodak Theatre wasn't there and stuff you
know when Hollywood was just a lot of
weirdos and stuff and you know even
taking the bus you know I used to take
the bus to school because I would go to
the valley to high school and we pick up
the bus at you know Gardner and sunset
and a lot of hookers and stuff and pimps
even in the morning still like when we
would be waiting for the bus I mean I
remember seeing the
you know prostitutes getting chased down
the street and stuff you know by with
the by the pimps and stuff yeah
how do you avoid all like flipping into
yeah slipping into I think being
surrounded by that environment I think
it kind of made me something yeah
something like that it's like I didn't
need to be did your friends do it yeah
yeah they did yeah I think that added to
it more that may mean kind of not want
to be involved with it cuz I all my
friends were getting involved with you
know stuff you know so yeah I did
everything late to broth was I smoking
pot it's waning you did it all at once
cuz all my friends they were all just
doing it when they were like eleven you
know twelve I thought that should mean
crazy dog you know it was a commercial
than Spanish you just ask a little fast
you start beating the [ __ ] out your
little brother is stealing from your mom
yeah fool has like dark eyes and [ __ ]
like you got your own watch yeah I saw
you this funny and more water commercial
this little boy saying my brother and I
we used to run around the time play cash
play football but now all I want to do
now is sit alone in a room watching a TV
bro but there's nothing obvious all hi
well yeah like what I used to think that
all the drugs were the same and I was
afraid of doing anything because of
those messages but mostly because I
didn't like I didn't like being on
rollercoasters and that was out of
control enough for me and I didn't want
to like put something in my body that
would make me out of could think you're
in a roller coaster no or just feel like
something I couldn't stop or take back I
mean that was part of it to the eighties
definitely were had an effect those
messages you know like definitely they
worked for me too actually I mean I mean
I like cuz I were a transcoding like I
never did that's my girl but I remember
seeing this short film and in class it
was like on a filmstrip you know and
they were like this kid drank alcohol
and then he like got shrunk and like hit
his head and he's all bloody and stuff
and I was like I guess I won't shrink
you know that was it
I don't maybe he got AIDS also he knows
I better not
I just watched his anti alcoholic
commercial like I'm never gonna drink
and he showed it to like being mean at
work right and getting [ __ ] up at the
bar and then he gets home and all the
kids like the road thrown under the
blanket scared and their dog sleeping
with a mom a skier and a fool Kicks down
the door and he goes he says the little
woman what he just his only language the
little warm and he was about to [ __ ]
everybody up sure that wasn't that one
of those Mormon commercials where the
one of the parents comes home angry and
then they change their attitude now you
know some of those kind of like they're
funny they're not meant to be funny but
they're funny because they're kind of
they're over the top right do you agree
with that now there's these these PSAs I
was watching recently I mean they're
they're old and I've seen him for years
but we were watching him recently trying
to show him as some people they're
really over-the-top and they're funny
maybe we can even pull them up right now
but these Canadian PSAs about domestic
abuse and it's not a funny subject but
these commercials are so over the top
that it's kind of funny actually and I
think a lot it's very divisive though
because I think a lot of people won't
find it funny at all but I wonder if you
guys would think it was funny what do
they say well should we watch them can
we watch them well I mean people
watching this will think it's not funny
probably but some people here might not
think it's my audience but they're so
over the top it's funny though I think
it's just like dant banned Canadian PSAs
or something like that yeah see that
Handmaid's Tale goes on tonight
oh my god what happened fool did you see
the way they got picked up camera
hearted throw him in here oh my god did
you see Bill Bellamy response you're
hilarious
no I just see now I was driving dude so
I just checked it real quick dude yeah
she was
I mean that's one of them right there
that she spilled my coffee but that's I
want to show you another one first and
then that one next to mine once again my
son people might not
oh it's both it's both okay yeah it's
both now you again Pete this is not
gonna be funny to some people but it is
here so I just fullscreen this before
people are gonna think it's not funny
but it it's so over the top that it's
kind of funny but it does have a point
I don't know you'll see how does that
work Emma okay oh we can't hear it - oh
okay never mind anyway she's
hey how you doing there yeah he's like
he's like he goes oh yeah oh my god she
spilled my coffee [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh this
is hair afterwards our Canadian yeah
yeah they didn't because because they're
I think it's cuz it was so anger
management it's for abuse domestic abuse
domestic abuse echo actually Oh actually
goes those results are correct she's
like you stupid [ __ ] she's [ __ ] you
[ __ ] cow you cut he says yet I think he
straightens this tie at the end there's
just something kind of I don't know
there's some curtsies a madman alright
domestic abuse abuse right when you do
that you're beaten oh there's everybody
your wife yeah well the slope the slogan
is you couldn't you wouldn't get away
with it here what you shouldn't be able
to get away with it at home I was
putting it into a different place yeah
exactly been my feeling like why is
domestic abuse reserved or just
relegated to domestic you know why is it
different
an assault on the street by a stranger
I've always felt like that that's a good
idea I didn't know that that's what that
we're going yeah but no time I guess the
the reaction even though it's it's
they're probably you know realistic
reaction that we could because if you
had you know some guys Billy milk and
then you beat it with a belt you know
like some people do that to kids
yeah right you know you're at a bar
you're free Peter than solid you gotta
beat the [ __ ] on him with sticks treated
adults like they do child abuse do you
get spanked for dropping milk or is
feeling something no you don't ever
knock anything I won't say nothing
because it's a little boy and it's like
also their little hands don't always
pick up cups the city's as easily as we
do and fools cubby enough uh I'm not
going on the road I think I'm gonna go
on the road later this year but well I'm
trying to try to do this thing in town
and if it doesn't pan out then I
probably ought to do it well I'm trying
to like sell the show but in May and
then that doesn't pan out I'm probably
just gonna get on the road again well
you were pitchy - oh yeah yeah you know
- who different people you know I'm
trying I'm pitching - uh
Kevlar who Canada Kendler Canada Oh
Canada yeah yeah
officially the CBC I got these this
whole like slew of PSAs and I'm trying
to pitch the candidate their milk
commercials what'd he say no it's just
somebody here I know man but he's a fan
now he needed a comment he needs either
anybody who are the video and watch it
itself is oh yeah whether you like it or
not
we got you got you sucker whether you
not like it or not whether you're a fan
we took time away from you yeah we
robbed you here we took two minutes we
took five second we took we took it from
you you can never have it back whether
you like it or not you have to go rent
right my special appealing the
mainstream you're gonna do it I know it
you can't stop now what's over that one
comment though McDonald's has the best
chocolate chip cookies that's a bit of
ice cream roll my dice cream that you
put nothing caramel in that bro that and
am/pm I didn't even know they had
charged and you can make your own cone
there Mel I walked out with a cold Islam
bro
I thought they call me dumb King you
know it used to be good and for me in
high school was a jack-in-the-box tacos
feel good I'm so glad I haven't had them
in a long time but you get two tacos for
99 cents I will get ten bro it was just
so fast it will cut my mouth
they were good actually when they cut
your mouth because they over try them
you know what's the next level go and
dip a bit ranch as you go with Lisa bro
now how did he write this is what I put
on 40 pounds yeah less you know B but
she will get the chicken at the spicy
chicken with cheese I love you
not only that I got mozzarella sticks
and it was 3:00 in the morning and I'm
picking out like this and then wonder
how I will come home from our like a
four-day binge I was like oh I'll be so
hungry I'll be like you just stop I'm
checking the box and I will get that the
double bacon
so cream cheese burger bro it was a it
was a sourdough bread and it was doable
two patties was just mayonnaise and
white cheese
bacon onions net sliced tomatoes and
tomato ya know how that was strawberry
shake
fries and a soda and he'd sleep for two
days I should brought you back to life
huh probably cry for 30 minutes it's
also great enough to you buy everything
I did it
hey are you gonna do are you guys best
friends or you are you best friends
I mean no I'm still I mean no I mean
that's why oh you're not best friends
you have the same answer William yeah
here they'll here the best friend oh yes
but I have a little bit for anywhere
else you have any you know what Vinnie
Vinnie is the name that illustration of
you that we couldn't tell who it is
that's what that person's name would be
you know I mean does that look like a
Vinny that looks like a Vinny that guy's
hair looks like so Vinny's your best
friend
yeah probably only you who's your best
friend I don't know I would think you
would think his wife would be his best
friend but he has told me before he
doesn't like me he loves me I do love
her but what did you love your best
friend oh yeah yeah you wouldn't like
your best friend and like to hang out
but loves deep breath I don't except
there's a different part cause you want
to start a family with your best friend
asking if you went to Cal with Marshawn
Lynch no no wait who's Marshawn Lynch he
the Oakland Raiders running back he went
to Berkeley
he went to Cal Berkeley yeah no you went
to school with I don't know what year
did he go maybe football
do I look like I like football does it
look like somebody that would put on a
Jersey go Raiders
I played tennis night some fool killed
me with the Commons oh that's MCA from
the Beastie Boys yes I get that all the
time
I get Beastie Boys all the time any time
someone says that any time if someone
says oh you look like a Beastie Boys
would be like oh I never know give this
[ __ ] right here Aaron Stein is
Bill
or under the table I hope so why would
it be under the table you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
you knows troll troll something fun yeah
actually is kind of funny in a way think
about it if pill Burt was under the
table what would he be doing under the
table
no like I know massaging or massaging
are actually billboards but now now that
we're talking about Bill Murray's
messing with the wires actually we're
back I'm back all right bill can you fix
that I'm not even gonna move are we
recording
once we caught once we called out bill
burr for being at the table he shifted
around and they messed up
okay oh there we go there goes there
goes again I mean it's you got it yeah
it's yet to acknowledge something that
there's there's there must be I'm a big
timing of talking about Bill burr being
on the table and then this happening is
that's interesting actually yeah so it
with me yeah sure to Lisa also taking
the course it did hear a shout out to
Bill burr actually
massaging those feet making us
comfortable yeah I know man what's so
fool was so full you do any shoutouts
you want to give any shout out to
anybody
yeah I want to give a shout out to car
cane dedicated dedicated listener
dedicated viewer Francisco know
everybody everybody who's gonna go out
yeah I don't know how I was Marcia how
old is Marshawn Lynch 36 yeah yeah we we
didn't probably well I don't
I don't know might have been cottage
each other at the same time to school at
Marshall Lynch how about that one that
one did we know that the comedians are
though I went to college with Brett
Favre dog was so full of jiggle your
show coming up Saturday man Saturday
we're at at sage and Whitney slappers
comedy club I'll be there with WX that's
the original stage right there yeah
someplace right there on when I was
talking about the room I told somebody
they was at a hotel that's another one
dude that was like up the street from
the slapper but that guy in the hotel
back in the day with Medina yeah Rudy
Medina and no that was before too -
that's another so what I'm gonna do hook
of the moments the bastion Cetina hook
me over the show and the Whittier
Sheraton and I think was a theme that
when he slept it could remember that and
had that Club across the street it was
called a veces so nice yeah nice leopard
runs every Friday Saturday loop where is
it where is it in Whittier California
yeah yeah so I'm a shout out to the
people at nice lappers comedy show if
you're out there and with you go check
out the real tourists you performing
this weekend yeah I mean I'm at The
Improv at 10:30 10:30 show the lab or
the regular room all right shake him out
people I have nothing me I'll be
swimming bro I'm back like Michael
Phelps yeah man what's up fool podcast
shout out to Freddie Korea
what's his podcast thanks for the invite
and we do have we're gonna have a
podcast testimo and we're gonna invite
him and I buy that also two girls from
the podcast drama club drama club we're
gonna have them on it whatever
I was so food thank you very much
everybody for listening thanks Brent why
I'm back thanks for having me check out
that special pin main string check it
out check it out
funny guy you will not be disappointed
very hilarious people